herzlich willkommen zum heutigen video
leute ihr seht es schon hinter mir steht
ein eimer voll mit schleim leute seht
ihr das und was machen wir heute ganz
einfach wir haben uns beide 5 wahrheiten
und fünf ungehalten ausgedacht und
müssen erraten ob der andere gelogen hat
oder ob es die wahrheit war wenn wir
richtig liegen passiert gar nichts wenn
er falsch liegen kriegen wir schon so
eine handvoll schleim auf die backe
falls du dich nach in der heide
überhaupt nicht nimmt das irgendwie gibt
es nach schlimmstem einen kanal schon
video gemacht über nacht wurden dann
habe ich mich umgezogen habe meine haare
gemacht meinte max so auch ja übrigens
die muster der haare nicht machen weil
sich gerade fertig war sebastian kriegt
jetzt die erste aussage von mir
vorgelesen muss entscheiden ob es wahr
oder falsch dass die erste aussage von
max ist ich bin ohne führerschein schon
mal auto gefahren wo auf welcher straße
einfach generell habe ich jemals schon
auto gefahren bin bevor ich den
führerschein hatte wahrheit
hier steht einer lüge der mauer du bist
doch locker auf unserem grundstück mal
gefahren lüge alter damen du bist
traktor gefahren
trotz dieser aussicht ich leider nur
damit du alles zinsen und ok dann jetzt
abwechseln ich bin der typ der welt für
eine sehr subjektive das ist objektiv
nachweisbar ist auf jeden fall diese
seien dann stimmt da war geschickt das
wundert mich jetzt weniger haben sie
wahrscheinlich war nicht ganz klar was
hier geht es geht hier um die nächste
aussage von max ist ich habe mir noch
nie etwas gebrochen
[Musik]
also habe ich mir schon etwas gebrochen
ist es eine wahrheit
liebe die aussagen aber ich habe
irgendwie eigentlich errichtung von
irgendwas dabei aber meist nicht hast
die chance gebrochen
nicht die puppe spielen solche die sagen
ich würde sagen also ab geht komm papa
ist ja nichts geworfen
sebastians nächste aussage ist ich habe
während meiner zeit in spanien mit mehr
als allem mädchen kontakt gehabt kontakt
in anführungsstrichen das halt so lange
her
ich glaube du hast sogar von der
sprachschule eine kennengelernt also
sage ich ja wahrheit märz kontakt ja
richtig mit wie viel sind wahrheit oder
lüge hat das spiel ja okay machen echte
aussage ist ich habe mir noch nie eine
falsche identität überlegt um
interessanter zu wirken und leute zu
verarschen kann man das sogar seit wird
wenn man kann es mit der raschen es wird
also ein schmucker alter wie kann man so
begreifen ist dass der perverse aller
zeiten als er noch nie 'ne falsche
identität und leute zu verarschen
jetzt hast du das gemacht mache phono
locker ab rang als wären seine ich meine
persönlich sondern leute triffst du was
überlegen wo von sägen hey ich bin ja
nun geht das war halt ne und bastians
nächste aussage fresh und meist match
ist scheiße also ich nehme das schon
ernst und überlegt mir folgen
was ist kacke alles möglich ist scheiße
das ist die wahrheit gepachtet immer so
oftmals dann wenn du mir jetzt eine
stelle gibt es musst du dir fashion
night special kaufen weil diese feier
mir ist es für mich viel mehr strom und
ich merke das ist so pervers
wie kommt man doch hier war das nicht
weil es so fest gehauen max nächste
aussage ich kann ein rückwärtssalto auf
dem trampolin ja gesagt so willst du
nicht ich will größer als mein kleiner
bruder du [ __ ] max nächste aussage
ich habe mir noch nie die haare gefärbt
also sax weitere liebe
das macht sie nur die haare gefärbt ich
kann nicht aufhören
noch nie wie also nie mit milch prüf
habe bestimmt schon mal die demokratie
kommt aus amerika ja ok max nächste
aussage ich habe mich und meine freunde
eine zeitlang homies genannt naja ich
glaube ich auch gleich bedeutet dass wir
uns nächste aussage ich habe in indien
keine attraktiven inneren getroffen und
war ganz nah online gucken auf den boden
die wracks nächste aussage ich kann
problemlos rückwärts skifahren stimmt
liege er was ich kann relativ beim
schwimmen ich kann doch kein du hast mir
sogar videos geschickt wie die rhythmik
ski fährst hab ich kann es nicht
problemlos gesorgt dass jetzt
problembehafteter zugefallen war ich
kann nicht klar
ich halte mich nicht gerne länger an
einem ort auf also bad eingeschlossen
das mit lügen würde ich sagen war das
fest ohne diesen festen ein
max nächste aussage ich habe im englisch
abitur 15 punkte
weil er darauf sollte etwa sie haben
ende in der mündlichen prüfungen weniger
als normal okay was ihr ins nächste
aussage ich mag billige klamotten bei
max nächste aussage ich war schon mal im
dark knight nein war er nicht ich denke
da kann jemand ob wir sebastians nächste
aussage ich habe in indien ein bier für
15 euro getrunken stunden club war wie
mit problem das skifahren
nee ich kann es noch besser mit
problemen verpasst ich hätte ein
drastisches ich mache jetzt einfach ganz
leicht das ehren loses dem video aller
zeiten max letzte aussage abonniert
kernkraft
da wird keiner vergessen im palast das
ist keine aussage in dem sinne dass sie
überhaupt ja okay du denkst jetzt
irgendwas aus wahrscheinlich aber weil
du sagst es war aussage ich habe in der
schulzeit über 17 sekunden auf 100
metern gebracht
14 15 da sagen die leute wenn euch die
regierung beobachte ich mag jetzt
springen sagte neid
das ist nie gefallen hat